which is correct a dozen eggs is or a
dozen eggs are I remember being in
elementary school and my teachers making
a big deal about the unit and I never
really got that until one day I was in
the grocery store and I wanted to buy an
apple but I couldn't buy one Apple I had
to buy a whole bag of apples so I did I
bought one bag of apples I took it home
I took one apple out of the bag and I
cut it up and then I ate one slice one
bag one Apple one slice which of these
is the real one well they all are of
course and that's what my elementary
teachers were trying to tell me because
this is the important idea behind whole
number place value decimal place value
and fraction our whole number system
depends on being able to change what we
count is one our whole number system
depends on being able to change units
there are two ways to change units we
can compose and we can partition when we
compose units we take a bunch of things
we put them together to make a bigger
thing like a dozen eggs we take 12 eggs
put them together to make a group and we
call that group a dozen a dozen eggs is
a composed unit other examples of
composed units include a deck of cards a
pair of shoes a jazz quartet and of
course Barbie and Ken make a couple but
think about a loaf of bread that's not a
composed unit because we don't get a
whole bunch of slices from a whole bunch
of different bakeries and put them
together to make a loaf no we start with
a loaf of bread and we cut it into
smaller pieces called slices so each
slice of bread is a partitioned unit
other examples of partitioned units
include a square of a chocolate bar a
section of an orange and a slice of
pizza the important thing about units is
that once we've made a new unit we can
treat it just like we did the old unit
we can compose composed units and we can
partition partition units think about
toaster pastries they come in packs of
two and then those packs get put
together in sets of four to make a box
so when I buy one box of toaster
pastries am i buying one thing four
things or eight things it depends on the
unit one box four packs eight pastries
and when I share a slice of pizza
friend we have to cut it into two
smaller pieces so a box of toaster
pastries is composed of composed units
and when I split a slice of pizza and
partitioning a partition unit but what
does that have to do with math in math
everything is certain two plus two
equals four and one is just one but
that's not really right one isn't always
one here's why we start counting at one
and we count up to nine one two three
four five six seven eight nine and then
we get to ten and in order to write ten
we write a one and A zero that one means
that we have one group and the zero
helps us remember that it means one
group not one thing but ten just like
one just like a dozen eggs just like an
egg ten is a unit and ten tens make a
hundred so when I think about 100 it's
like the box of toaster pastries is 100
one thing ten things or 100 things and
that depends on what one is it depends
on what the unit is so think about all
the times in math when you write the
number one no matter what place that one
is in no matter how many things that one
represents one is
you